our trans people gay what surgery to
trans people have and trans people have
sex yes
end of story hi my name's Ryan I'm
Charley Martin so my name is Ellis
Johnson and I'm proud to say that I'm
also a trans woman I identify as a trans
man there are all kinds of questions
floating around the internet let's clear
the air what does transgender mean well
good question
because I think there's still a lot of
people that don't fully understand the
real basics so for me to put it simply I
was I pronounced male at birth but
identify his female and so I'm
transgender because I've changed my
exterior gender presentation to match
how I feel an easy working definition to
think of is that it is somebody who
doesn't identify with the sex or the
gender they were assigned when they were
born and in this country at the moment
you have to be classed as either male or
female within six weeks of birth and
that sticks with you then for the rest
of your life really unless you're
transgender in which case you identify
something other than the sexual agenda
that you were assigned how do you know
if you're trans okay so I came across a
really good metaphor for explaining this
recently the first time you picked up a
pen or a ball or a tennis racket and you
try to use it how did you know which
hand to use you tried it with one hand
and then you tried it with the other
hand and one hand felt natural
on one hand felt unnatural when you're
walking around with the wrong gender
identity and the wrong gender expression
you just know it feels unnatural how do
people react to when you came out as
trans my mum sorry if you're watching
this and she didn't react
very well I thought it was gonna be a
lot worse than it actually was in my own
mind I'm not trying to say it was easy
because it wasn't at all but I think
from my point of view I'd probably spent
25 years worrying and I built up into
this horrible thing in my mind that
nobody would want to know me or be my
friend or anything
most people were actually just really
supportive my uncle and I aren't like
they're great they the first things they
asked were what pronounce doing is and
what name do you like you want me to use
for you and is there anything we can do
to make it easier there was only one
person and I won't forget them she threw
her arms around me and sort of squealed
and went congratulations this is amazing
what do you need from me what can I do
anyone who was quite negative about it I
just choose to cut them off as meanness
that sounds but you kind of have to put
yourself first and that how trans people
gay they can be your gender identity is
something that's in here it's in your
head and it's also I think it's in your
heart you know it's kind of in your soul
it's what it's who you feel you are who
you feel you are it's completely
independent of who you're attracted to
so these are two very distinct things
that shouldn't be confused
I personally am but like that's just me
personally I know and I told people that
I was trans initially quite a few people
were like oh is this because you want to
be with a guy and I was just like no no
no this has nothing to do with that what
surgery do trans people have firstly the
main thing to think about is that not
all trans people will have surgery not
all trans people will want or need
surgery but I think it's really
important to not focus too much on this
idea of surgery because most of the time
or a lot of the times specifically in
the media trans people are reduced to
body parts most times people will be
very offended if somebody else-- them
that question it's a very individual
thing and it's really quite a personal
thing as well something that quite often
I get asked by people what surgery if I
had be careful about why you're asking
that
and in nine times out of ten you
probably don't need to know about it so
steer clear of asking surgery questions
unless a trans person wants to offer you
that information or it wants some
support maybe they want to talk about it
but be careful not to ask on your own
terms because trans bodies are not for
entertainment how are trans people
treated like Robert Hirsch honestly
mm-hmm how long have we got
trans people at the moment are treated
as a trend we treated as being dangerous
we're treated as being abnormal and
probably yeah mentally ill as well
there's lots of ways we treated that are
really terrible trans people suffer a
huge amount of discrimination and it's
really really frustrating because it
doesn't need to happen
I think if most people could live a week
in a trans person shoes their whole
perspective would change it's something
that I hate see see happen in my
lifetime what is the question you wish
people asked you just kind of wish
people would ask more about me as a
person then inherently going straight
into the deep trans questions I wish
that people would ask me is what I've
read true how can I be a better Ally to
the trans community it's probably the
question I wish people would ask thanks
for watching don't forget to subscribe
and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon